adam tasca bonjour 12e avenue au bistrot
du théâtre monsigny
je vous en prie catherine tasca
sénatrice des yvelines depuis 2004 vous
êtes aujourd'hui dans l'opposition au
sénat vous avez été dans la majorité
sous la précédente mandature au côté de
jean-pierre bel vous aviez d'ailleurs
était candidate pour cette présidence
est-ce que vous avez des regrets de ne
pas avoir réussi à obtenir le plateau
bas bien sûr bien sûr c'était c'était un
vrai un vrai projet donc il n'a pas
abouti j'ai forcément un petit regret
mais le temps a passé mais ça n'a pas
abouti vous vous le savez qu est ce qui
m qu'est-ce qui a manqué c'est quoi
c'est un jeu politicien ou sait plus sur
les convictions
donc je pense que les convictions
étaient tout à fait comparable entre
jean pierre bel est et moi même ce qui a
été marquant en 2011 c'est que la gauche
devienne majoritaire ou au sénat c'est
ça l'événement ensuite le choix entre
les candidats à la présidence là ça se
fait et celui qui gagne gagne et depuis
c'est gérard larcher qui est retourné à
la tête du sénat puisque le sénat a
rebasculé à droite la dernière fois à
votre place et c'est lui d'ailleurs qui
était invité de cette émission et
lorsqu'on parlait de ce mandat de
sénateur et nous expliquer ce qui
l'intéressait c'était surtout la
proximité avec tous ces élus du
territoire est ce que c'est ça aussi qui
vous passionne vous intéresse dans ce
mandat de sénatrice oui absolument j'ai
vécu le meddat le mandat de député dans
cette circonscription d'ailleurs qui a
beaucoup d'intérêt au 6 mai le mandat au
sénat nous nous tiens très très proche
des élus des élus locaux
ça donne une
vraie vision de la diversité du
territoire et dieu sait que dans les
yvelines il est divers notre territoire
et on a affaire des élus qui ont en
charge des collectivités de taille
extrêmement différente extrêmement
différentes
donc ça donne un vrai panorama sur la
vie de la france la vie réelle vous
l'avais dit aux joueurs vous avez été
député aujourd'hui sénatrice vos
collègues sénateurs quelquefois vous les
égratigner un petit peu parce qu'il ya
tout juste un an vous disiez qu'il
s'était développée chez certains
sénateurs presque une habitude d'emplois
fictifs
là vous pointiez du doigt l'absentéisme
ça va mieux pour cette nouvelle session
parlementaire
sachant qu'il ya des nouvelles règles
qui ont été mises en place avec gérard
larcher il ya des sanctions financières
en fait pour ceux qui ne sont pas là
assez souvent entre autres oui et puis
je pense qu'une vraie prise de
conscience chez l'ensemble des
parlementaires c'est pas facile pour eux
d'être présent au sénat il faut le
savoir aussi nous avons des vrais
obligations en circonscription et pour
nous c'est l'ensemble du département et
le département il est il est vaste pour
être présents aux quatre coins des
yvelines il faut beaucoup bougé ça prend
beaucoup de temps
or le l'emploi du temps le
du sénat est devenu de plus en plus
lourd de plus en plus chargées de retour
de loi examiné de texte trop de textes
trop de textes trop long qui traite des
problèmes multiples dans le même texte
est donc une vraie difficulté pour les
sénateurs ceci étant et surtout avec la
loi du non cumul des mandats que nous
avons fait passer il faut faire ce choix
et pendant que l'on exercé ce mandat je
pense qu'il est aussi important d'être
présent dans les débats au sénat que
d'être sur son territoire
votre actualité aujourd'hui au sénat
c'est le projet de loi relatif au droit
des étrangers
le texte a été adopté hier par hier par
à l'assemblée vous vous êtes non il a
été adopté par le sénat et
malheureusement dans une rédaction qui
est quasiment l'envers du texte tel
qu'il nous était arrivé du gouvernement
et de l'assemblée nationale
c'est la raison pour laquelle le groupe
socialiste a voté contre le texte
alors oui justement va revenir un petit
peu sur ces différents textes parce que
vous vous êtes opposés sur certains
points aussi de ce qui avait été
présenté au tout départ ça allait
corriger si je dis une bêtise mais vous
étiez opposé à l'une des dispositions
qui avait été présenté par les
socialistes et c'était une nouvelle
infraction aux quatre d'usurpation de
documents d'identité ça ça permettrait
de lutter contre les filières de
l'immigration clandestine
alors expliquez nous un petit peu plus
les choses mais tout simplement nous
estimons que s'agissant des réfugiés de
ceux qui sont en demande d'asile est en
fait c'est à eux que
l'on pense le plus en ce moment le fait
de se déplacer et d'entrées en france
sans papiers ou avec des faux papiers et
souvent assez inévitable lorsque vous
quittez un régime politique vous vous
sentez opprimés menacé vous ne voyagez
pas forcément vers les bons papiers et
donc un problème à l'entrée sur le
territoire
ça ne facilite pas le travail de
contrôle à l'entrée sur le territoire
mais en tout cas nous avons estimé que
ça ne méritait pas la sanction qui était
dans le texte initial
j'aimerais qu'on parle un petit peu des
socialistes de cette majorité du travail
qui a été mené depuis de votre regard
parce que vous êtes dans politique de
depuis longtemps engagée depuis
longtemps aux côtés des socialistes mais
pour ça on va faire une petite pause et
on va aller s'installer de l'autre côté
en salle je vous en prie allez-y
catherine tasca juste avant cette petite
pause nous évoquions le parti socialiste
alors je vais rappeler que vous avez été
ministre de la communication michel
rocard ministre délégué à la
francophonie d'edith cresson ministre de
la culture et de la communication de
lionel jospin
quelques-unes de vos nombreux nombreuses
fonctions au ps depuis toujours tout
simplement vous pensez quoi aujourd'hui
de l'action de françois hollande gens
pensent du bien
il a repris un dossier difficile un pays
profondément fragilisé inquiet et et je
pense que il s'inscrit dans un travail
de long terme de manière à accompagner
le redressement du pays
vous êtes de la nisa mais il reste assez
peu de temps dans son mandat et dans le
cadre du mandat mais d'abord il est
permis d'espérer
il aura l'occasion de prolonger son
action dans un deuxième
mandat au fonds actuellement les
sondages lui sont guère favorables et
nous savons que les français sont
assez perturbé par l'évolution de la
situation économique et sociale et ne
voit pas encore suffisamment de
résultats de l'action entreprise par le
président de la république et par son
gouvernement
il ya donc une impatience
et l'action qui est menée en deux à dix
ans je pense qu'elle va dans le bon sens
oui
elle s'efforce de concilier nos
engagements de toujours nos convictions
de gauche de socialistes et la réalité
pas seulement du pays mais de
l'environnement dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons c'est à dire l'europe
c'est-à-dire un cadre international qui
est profondément troublé déséquilibré et
au milieu de tout ça je pense que
françois hollande donne des chances au
pays de se redresser alors pourtant à
gauche on entendait des sondés des voix
dissonantes en tout le monde ne soutient
pas son action vous serez bien forcément
vous êtes plutôt emmanuel macron martine
aubry je crois que je peux prétendre
être les deux à la fois avec la fois
être martine aubry si vous voulez dire
martine aubry est ce que ces deux
sondeurs fait partie des pouilles ces
deux orientations faire ensuite pas de
ce côté-là corps n'est pas prêt mais je
pense que manuel macron est un bon
ministre sérieux je considère l'ensemble
de l'action du gouvernement est de mon
point de vue le
gouvernement tel qu'il est constitué
actuellement fait du bon travail je lui
fais confiance les deux tendances
peuvent cohabiter c'est une tendance
plutôt gauche de la gauche que je
n'existais pas quand vous lisez
l'histoire des partis socialistes depuis
ses origines
je lis actuellement une une biographie
de léon blum
écrit par jean lacouture qui vient de
disparaître
et je suis frappé de ce que ces deux
lignes on va dit où ces deux tentations
sont présentes en permanence dans
l'histoire du parti socialiste donc ça
n'est pas surprenant
ce qui est actuellement plus surprenant
c'est que par rapport au contexte
politique dans lequel nous sommes
versées en particulier la montée de
l'extrême droite et le durcissement des
positions
la droite dite classique par rapport à
ce contexte je pense que la
confrontation entre ces deux des
guillemets courant au sein du ps est une
confrontation dangereuse c'est une
confrontation qui est destructrice
par ailleurs vous le savez nos
partenaires à gauche ne sont pas non
plus en accord avec la politique menée
par françois hollande c'est donc pour
nous un un problème de fond c'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
premiers secrétaires du parti socialiste
lance une consultation très libre ce
week end sur les attentes des français
par rapport à l'union de la gauche
moi je suis convaincu que les français
souhaitent l'union de la gauche des
biens je souhaitais l'union met donc il
ya cet appel lesquelles quelque part cet
appel peut sembler un peu un trip
désespoir regardez les français veulent
qu'on dit qu'on parte vers une union il
faut réussir à s'unir il faut se mettre
d'accord portant il ya des divergences
de fond il ya des problèmes de fond sur
le programme est une vraie nécessité a
donné la parole aux citoyens sur ces
sujets que c'est la bonne affaire car
soit on s'aperçoit que les
confrontations entre appareils ne sont
pas très fructueuse
je le dis en le regrettant mais c'est
comme ça pour le moment c'est un moment
de l'histoire de la gauche des gauches
en france et au fond tous les partis
sont à la recherche d'un d'un contact
d'un dialogue plus directe avec nos
concitoyens
le référendum n'est qu'une forme parmi
bien d'autres
chercher à avoir ce dialogue il ya tout
de même une urgence parce qu'il ya des
élections régionales
vous me disiez tout à l'heure en aparté
que vous connaissez bien le département
des yvelines ça fait une vingtaine
d'années que vous y êtes arrivé vous
avez connu les victoires les défaites
aussi le conseil départemental
aujourd'hui n'a plus d'élus d'opposition
de gauche
il est détenu uniquement par la droite
les agglomérations les communes ont
basculé aux dernières municipales
l'agglomération salade ligne on se
trouve aujourd'hui était tenue par la
droite par le centre droit avec les
régionales il ya un vrai risque
vous êtes inquiète de voir cette région
échapper aux socialistes
je ne cache pas du tout mon inquiétude
parce que ce serait je pense une
régression pour ce territoire de l'île
de france et pour notre territoire des
yvelines à l'évidence donc moi je
souhaite beaucoup que nous puissions
conserver la direction de de cette
région ont la gauche un bilan solide
jean paul huchon a fait avec ses
partenaires pas tout seul a fait un
grand travail sur cette région et ce
serait tout à fait désolant que tout ça
soit puisse être remis remis en cause ou
savez vous évoquez le conseil
départemental ça n'est bon pour personne
une composition monocolore la
composition actuelle mais les électeurs
au clan ont choisi louis les élèves
c'est la démocratie aussi les électeurs
ont choisi mais je le répète ce n'est
bon pour personne c'est un département
de toute façon et je suis certain qu'ils
jamais penchée et fortement gauche
histoire sur quelques territoires
quelques villes et malheureusement nous
en avons perdu quelques unes mais que le
conseil départemental avec sa mission
avec ces nouvelles compétences puissent
être gérés par une seule famille
politique je le répète je pense que ça
n'est bon pour personne et que même si
c'est le résultat
objectif des élections départementales
et c'est d'ailleurs dans la dans la
suite des élections municipales de 2014
même si c'est le verdict des électeurs
ça donne un résultat qui à mon avis ne
sera pas fructueux pour ce territoire
vous souvenez de votre arrivée dans le
département des yvelines très bien c'est
un parachutage même s'il a le moins
c'est un oui mais bon je suis pas très
sportive jamais imaginé arriver les
barques et mais oui mais rappelez vous
que c'est un moment où
gouvernement
où exactement les socialistes avaient
choisi de travailler sur la parité et
sur l'entrée d'un certain nombre de
femmes en politique
voilà donc le parti m'a proposé de venir
dans les yvelines
cela a été diversement apprécié par mes
collègues élus socialistes ça je m'en
souviens bien
mais quand je me suis accroché et j'ai
pu être élu à l'assemblée nationale ce
dont j'étais très très fier et très
heureuse d'autant que j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir la présidence de la commission
des lois
en 97 donc voilà donc oui je me souviens
très précisément de cette arrivée qui a
été un peu bousculée par la décision de
dissolution de l'assemblée nationale
logiquement j'aurais eu du temps devant
moi pour préparer cette élection est mon
implantation dans les yvelines
il a fallu faire vite en préparant un
petit peu cet entretien j'ai retrouvé un
article et un portrait qui avait été
fait de vous dans libération c'est en 98
et la journaliste écrivait elle me
retient pas la lumière n'accroche pas
les objectifs des photographes se
détournent des journalistes ces piètres
vendeuse d'elle-même que l'on se demande
par quel mystère elle est devenue
quelqu'un au parti socialiste vous
souvenez de ce n'est pas du tout pas du
tout magazine haley la terminologie si
piètre vendeuse d'elle-même j'ai jamais
cherché à être vendeuse de moi même que
je pense qu'on s'impose beaucoup plus
parce que l'on fait par les idées qu'on
défend que par une raie un métier de
mise en lumière voilà bon je pense ne
pas être passée inaperçue dans tout ce
parcours avoir réalisé un certain nombre
de choses mais je me souvenais pas de
2,7 de cet article je ne me méfie pas
des journalistes
je dirais que j'ai appris à les
connaître notamment lorsque j'ai été au
gouvernement ministre de la
communication j'ai encore parlé de
connaître mieux que je ne les
connaissaient auparavant quand je
n'étais pas une élue nationale mais non
j'ai au contraire du respect pour le
métier de journaliste en 98 justement à
l'époque de ce portrait vous étiez en
train de travailler autour du projet du
pacs justement aujourd'hui quand vous
voyez toute l'agitation autour du
mariage pour tous
encore aujourd'hui même si la loi est
passée ça vous gagne ça vous agace un
peu
non ça ne m'agace pas vous dites je ne
sais pas beaucoup changé après tant
d'années oui sur le fond n'est-ce pas de
cour vous voulez douillet tout à faire
mais en fait même le mariage pour tous
il a été adopté et ça se passe très bien
dans la plupart des mairies de france
donc ça veut dire que c'est une réforme
qui était tout à fait jouable s'est
développé autour de ce projet un débat
très passionné passionnel très
politicien aussi
qui est plutôt regrettable parce que sur
ces questions sociales sociétales
nous aurions tous intérêt à ce que le
débat reste un peu plus paisible
je me suis toujours posé la question est
ce que nous n'aurions pas mieux fait de
perfectionner le pacs tel que nous
l'avions conscient 98 dont mais le choix
était met d'aller d'aller jusqu'au
mariage
et encore une fois ça se vit sans
problème dans 99% des cas
donc ça prouve qu'il y avait plus de
deux volontés d'agitation que deux
contre-projet ou de véritables réponses
france par rapport au fond de ce texte
vous avez été ministre j'ai dit tout à
l'heure je dresse un petit peu comme ça
votre parcours votre biographie vous
avez été une ministre emblématique de
françois mitterrand j'aimerais juste
qu'on s'attarde un petit peu là dessus
et on a réalisé un petit micro-trottoir
voici ce que les gens gardent comme
image le françois mitterrand vous
réagirez juste après on dira plutôt
bonne
parce qu'on était dans quand même encore
dans l'île dans les illusions image
quand même controversé parce que parce
que
parce que tout n'a pas toujours été
extrêmement clairs mais une bonne
présidence on va dire président social
version alors que les nouvelles versions
c'est un peu plus des qualités bien il a
bien travaillé on était bien avec le
recours à très clair en fait je trouve
qu'il ya eu beaucoup de choses cachées
donc plutôt une image négative une image
très positive
oui quelqu'un de très très cultivé très
érudit oui très positive tout cas pas
très bonne pourquoi parce que c'est un
tricheur
comme beaucoup d'hommes politiques vous
réagissez comme ans qu'elle avait gardé
les témoignages dans l'ensemble sont
très positifs c'est à dire qu'on sent
que même pour ceux qui peut-être n'ont
pas partagé tous les choix de françois
mitterrand entend président de la
république il y a une admiration et
avait ce sentiment que la france était
représentée au plus haut niveau et ça je
pense que les français ont besoin de ça
ils ont besoin de ça mais la dernière
phrase qui résume évidemment
l'opposition absolue c'est un tricheur
comme tous les comme tous les politiques
et là on touche à un état d'esprit un
état de l'opinion qui est préoccupant
parce que ça se traduit par l'abstention
voit la montée des extrêmes
c'est à dire que au fond les mauvais
exemples parmi les politiques ont
entaché et il y en a sur tous les bords
ont entaché l'image
d'ensemble des politiques et sain c'est
grave parce que nous avons besoin que
des gens se consacre à ses mandats
politiques c'est à ses fonctions et nous
avons besoin de la confiance des
français dans l'une de nos tâches
actuellement c'est de reconquérir cette
confiance on va faire une petite
digression va on va quitter la politique
juste pour parler de votre parcours
professionnel parce que notamment de
votre passage entre 93 et 97
vous étiez auprès d'andré rousselet le
fondateur de canal+ vous avez été sa
conseillère
ça consiste en quoi il ya en réalité il
m'a confié très réduite
la présidence d'une des filiales de
cannes a vu ce qu'était canal horizons
qui avait la charge de développer canal
en afrique
et puis c'était pour moi la première
expérience en entreprise privée
véritable j'avais dirigé des
établissements avec des statuts privés
mais
tous sur subsides publics est là pour la
première fois je plongeais vraiment dans
la réalité de l'entreprise et je pense
que c'est une expérience très très utile
que je tenais beaucoup à avoir une
activité professionnelle déconnecté du
monde politique parce que si j'avais un
regret exprimé par rapport à l'évolution
de l'exercice des mandats politiques
c'est que de plus en plus nous avons des
candidats qui n'ont pas d'expérience
professionnelle
la politique est un métier non c'est la
vie qu autre chose et je pense que c'est
un angle précédemment et sur le groupe
canal aujourd'hui si on fait une petite
parenthèse sur ce qu'il est devenu
avec le rachat par par bolloré j'ai
toujours pensé qu'une grande oeuvre
quelle qu'en soit la nature une grande
entreprise
ça tient beaucoup à son inventeur celui
qui l'a conçu en l'occurrence andré
rousselet il était très difficile que
canal continue sur sa lancée après
l'éviction de
d'andré rousselet est la preuve est
faite c'est qu'aujourd'hui la chaîne se
cherche un nouveau parcours qui de toute
façon à mon avis ne sera pas fidèle au
projet initial de canal plus ce qui se
passe dans le monde de la télé vous
intéresse toujours aujourd'hui beaucoup
notamment dans le service public aussi
l'ancien nazi parce que vous avez réagi
aussi sur la façon dont a été désignée
la nouvelle présidente de france
télévisions c'est un peu opaque
aujourd'hui c'est opaque je ne comprends
pas bien comment le conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel que j'étais quand il
décrit mettre en place parce que vous
avez c'est jérôme ancêtre du csa
oui mais surtout lorsque je suis devenu
ministre de la communication
nous avons par la loi créé ce conseil
supérieur de l'audiovisuel
je pense que nous n'avons pas vu tous
les problèmes et qu' il aurait des
choses à changer à la fois dans la
composition de ce conseil est dans sa
mission j'ai acquis la conviction qu'il
serait souhaitable que le conseil qui
est chargée de la régulation au fond
d'imprimer une déontologie aussi dans ce
paysage audiovisuel ne devrait pas être
celui qui désigne les responsables de
l'audiovisuel public et donc il y à là à
faire preuve d'imagination pour avoir
d'autres modes de
désignation le mode proposé par nicolas
sarkozy n'est pas pensable pas
acceptable de dire le président qui à
lui tout désigne mais je pense est la
démonstration a été faite à la fois pour
la nomination à radio france et pouvoir
la nomination à france télévisions que
dans sa composition dans sa façon de
fonctionner le conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel n'assume pas comme main il
serait souhaitable
cette mission de nomination alors oui
j'ai été critique la télé le théâtre
aussi là c'est votre premier amour 1 82
86 vous avez travaillé notamment avec
patrick chiron puis à partir de 1972
j'étais à la maison de la culture de
grenoble qui était très grand théâtre
pluridisciplinaire et puis j'ai
travaillé avec patrice à nanterre et son
des années pour moi très fructueuse et
très très heureuse j'ai une vraie
passion pour le théâtre mais je dirais
plus largement pour l'ensemble des arts
vivants et je crois que c'est une part
essentielle pour le devenir d'une
société pour le devenir de notre pays
d'ailleurs moi j'ai contracté la passion
politique à travers mon métier
dirigeants d'entreprises culturelles
lorsque j'ai fait très vite le lien
entre la politique culturelle la place
des arts dans la société et les choix
politiques fondamentaux qu'il fallait
faire
à travers l'action politique est en fait
c'est grenoble puis nanterre qui m'ont
amené un parcours politique plus
je pas plus engagé mais à travers à
travers l'élection et vous aimeriez y
retourner à l'issue du scrutin la presse
à l'issue du monde le sénateur je
pourrais aller beaucoup plus librement
encore au théâtre au concert et dans les
expositions
parce que vous savez que l'activité
parlementaire est en tout cas au sénat
est absolument dévorante et ne nous
laisse pas beaucoup d'espacé pour vivre
autre chose que l'on n'est pas l'heure
du théâtre national à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines qui est juste
on vous n'y allez pas souvent non je ne
vais pas souvent je la bougie vais quand
même de temps en temps mais les soirées
sont souvent consacrées au sénat
dernière question le parcours que vous
avez eue vous l'avais imaginé quand vous
étiez plus petites ont coûté parce que
le mot lui si vous connaissiez un petit
peu ans déjà oui par votre père oui on
s'est pas attardé mais je ne me voyais
pas du tout avec un mandat politique ou
des responsabilités gouvernementales
ce qui était très clair pour moi très
tôt c'était le sens de du service public
mais je ne suis pas une femme d'appareil
et j'ai toujours un peu de mal par
rapport au fonctionnement des appareils
politiques et d'ailleurs le spectacle
que nous donne aujourd'hui j'irai
beaucoup de formations politiques je
regarde ce qui s'est passé à l'ump tout
au long de l'année passée je regarde ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui chez les verts
par exemple pour ne prendre que ces
exemples
ça conforte ma défiance à l'égard de la
vie d'appareils et c'est pour ça aussi
je suis convaincu et je l' ai toujours
été qu'il fallait avoir peut-être une
double vie c'est à dire une expérience
professionnelle réelle qui vous armes
dans les relations avec les autres dans
la compréhension aussi des des codes
sociaux des obligations à l'égard des
gens qui travaillent on a besoin de ça
et puis par ailleurs d'exercer à
certains moments de la vie les
responsabilités politiques
merci beaucoup catherine tasca mais elle
est revenue pour ce café politique mais
aussi à vous